This episode is sponsored by Squarespace.
Go to Squarespace.com/microcosmos to save
10% off your first purchase of a website or domain.
A lot happened in the year 2022.
Economies shifted, reigns ended, wars began.
So it is okay if you missed out on this little
bit of we think very important news:
Demodex have buttholes.
Now perhaps you have never thought
to wonder about this.
Perhaps you have never even heard of a Demodex
before and you’re just slowly putting together
that it must be related to the creature that
we are watching right now.
Yeah, the one that looks like a tardigrade
but weirder, which says a lot given that tardigrades
already look pretty weird to us.
So you might wonder why we would care if a
Demodex has a butthole or not.
Well, we care because they live on our face.
Demodex are a genus of tiny mites that build their
lives around the hair follicles of various animals.
And there are two species that are found on
humans: Demodex folliculorum and Demodex brevis.
They each have their own preferred nooks on
our faces, with Demodex folliculorum preferring
hair follicles, and Demodex brevis preferring
our sebaceous glands.
The mites we are looking at had the distinction
of coming straight from the face of our master
of microscopes, James, who saw a little black
dot on his forehead and was curious
what was going on inside.
So he simply scraped the spot with the side
of a microscope slide and took a look.
But these mites don’t always localize themselves
in neat little dots, so sometimes scientists
have to turn to other measures to study them.
In one NPR interview, a scientist described
applying glue to a microscope slide and then
sticking it to a person’s forehead so
as they peeled the slide off, the mites would
peel off too.
And look, we get it.
Learning that there are little animals crawling
around your face, it might be a little unsettling.
Even James, who spends just about every day
thinking about microbes, found himself initially
repulsed by what he found on his skin.
But then he realized that they look like tardigrades
with big butts.
And if we can all collectively love tardigrades
the way that we seem to, perhaps we can find some
space in our hearts for these mites.
They’re even cute under the harsh glare
of our UV light!
The mites are tiny, less than a millimeter
in length.
And you can see two distinct halves to their
body.
At one end—the tardigrade end, as we like
to call it in a purely unscientific way—are
eight stubby legs waving behind the Demodex’s
mouth.
At the other end are their gastrointestinal
organs and their genitals.
Those spherical droplets in their body are
oil droplets, the digested remains of the
sebum and moisturizer that Demodex like to
eat from our skin.
Now, if at this moment, your mind is conjuring
up images of the demodex wandering your face
in search of oil to eat, you can rest easy.
Well, for now at least.
They’re probably not wandering, they're
just chilling out inside your pores.
At night though, Demodex do like to party.
They emerge from your pores in search of each
other, looking for other mites to mate with.
And when they are done, they head back to
your pores to lay their eggs.
An adult Demodex folliculorum lays around
20-24 eggs in your hair follicles.
Within three to four days, the young Demodex will
hatch, emerging with only six legs weirdly enough.
As they develop into adulthood, the other
two legs will  develop as well.
Their life span will end a few weeks later,
at which point the dead mites will decompose
in your follicles or sebaceous glands, turning
the tiny little pockets of your skin into
little mite graveyards.
It's a lot, I know.
We keep trying to say that Demodex are cute
actually, but then we talk about little mite
mating parties and mite graveyards on your
skin, and none of that is cute.
But here’s the thing: we pretty much all
have them.
If you’re watching this video, you probably
have Demodex living in your face.
And if you don't now, you will eventually.
Now they usually spread through physical contact,
though a 2015 study found that we tend to primarily
pass them on via close contact with our family
members rather than strangers.
And when they have found your face, they’ll
probably stick around, hiding in your pores
and other spaces that make them hard to scrub
out.
Generally, that’s fine.
Demodex don’t wreak much havoc on your skin.
They can become too abundant, creating a distinctive
white sheen that dermatologists call
Demodectic frost.
That excess of mites is usually connected
to a decline in the immune system.
But these cases are very rare.
For a time, there was a theory that Demodex
could cause rosacea, because they were thought
to not have a butthole.
What do those things have in common
with each other?
Well the idea was that without an anus,
the Demodex couldn’t poop.
Instead, the Demodex would spend their short lives
accumulating waste in large cells in their
body, and storing it away.
And when they died, the feces would burst
from their bodies, releasing bacteria that
could then cause rosacea.
There are enough correlations between Demodex
and the occurrence of rosacea to leave us
considering that there could be a connection
between the two.
But we are here to vindicate the mites a little.
Because that mechanism is based on an idea
that would turn out to be very wrong, the
idea that Demodex don’t have an anus.
In 2022, scientists were studying the genes
within Demodex.
And among their results are some microscopy
images and these words, which we hope will
become a classic in the history of butthole
science:
There have been several reports that Demodex
does not have an anus, and when Demodex dies,
the accumulated waste spills into the pores
of the skin and leads to inflammation; this
is not correct.
We’ve talked before about just how mysterious
and confusing the history of anus evolution
is, and so we were excited to hear this news.
But the other results of the scientist’s
genetic study of the Demodex are also worth
learning more about because they reveal just how
strange our relationship with these creatures is.
In particular, the scientists found that the
Demodex are surprisingly simple, relying on
a small number of proteins to survive.
This likely drives their nocturnal behavior,
because they lack the compounds that allow
their relatives to survive at all in the daytime.
And this might be the result of just how
lonely the Demodex mites are, in an ecosystem
built out of our skin where they face few
threats and little competition.
They’re doing so well that they may require
less than they once did to survive.
And that has been pushing them—at least according
to these scientists—to a future where they
might be symbionts with us, much like bacterial
endosymbionts that have become fully embedded
in their hosts.
That is, for now, just a hypothesis.
If there comes a day when the hypothesis is
fulfilled, well what do we do then?
Do we consider them weird and creepy,
and maybe even a little rude?
Or do we accept them as part of us, as inevitable
as every other cell in our body?
Or perhaps it is both, as nuanced as any
other experience we have with our bodies.
Wonderful and terrible, all at once.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring
this episode.
Squarespace gives people a powerful and beautiful
online platform from which to create their website.
So whether you’re looking to create an online
portfolio, start a blog, or open an online
store, Squarespace can help you out.
Maybe it’s finally time to start that podcast
you’ve been thinking about.
Well, you can use a blog page to publish and
syndicate a podcast with Squarespace.
You can even use your Squarespace blog to
create an RSS feed so listeners can use their
preferred podcast service to subscribe and
download new episodes.
And they make it super simple to categorize,
schedule, and share those blog posts as well.
Squarespace also makes it easy to keep in
touch with your listeners.
You can interact with your community on your
Squarespace site through threaded comments
and replies, and can generate extra revenue
through members-only content.
Also if you decide you want to start selling
some merch to go along with that podcast,
Squarespace is a powerful ecommerce platform,
and you can even go the extra mile and add
third-party extensions to help you manage
inventory, streamline bookkeeping, and ship
products around the world.
And you can do all of this on one easy-to-use
platform.
So go to Squarespace.com to sign up for a
free trial, and when you’re ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com/microcosmos to save
10% off your first purchase of a website or domain.
One thing that you've got to know, as a Patreon
patron of Journey to the Microcosmos, is you
don't know where the next episode is going.
But you trust us, to go in the direction that
we want to go in to discover what we can discover
by not looking big but looking small.
The people on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons, and they are the reason
that we can do this.
If you would like to join them, you can go
to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss,
check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.